6 36 it is Ash Wednesday marking the
beginning of Lent 40 days until Easter
you may notice people with a cross of
ashes on their forehead later today
Lorna gretty is live in The Newsroom
this morning with the meaning of the
tradition of Ash Wednesday Lauren good
morning good morning yes it's one of the
most popular holy days with a lot of
church attendance it's a day of
repentance I spoke to an auxiliary
Bishop at the Diocese of Las Vegas he
says every Ash Wednesday Jesus teaches
us to pray to fast and to practice
almsgiving that is to be generous
the bishop says we are called to spend
the 40 days modeling Our Lives after
Jesus to resist evil and cling to Faith
he remained faithful to his heavenly
father and that's what he calls us to do
so in our lives we we have a uh an
ongoing call to conversion but it seems
to be heightened and focused for us all
he says the season is marked by going to
mass listening to the word of God and
receiving a blessing with the ashes in
the sight of a cross on our foreheads
the ashes symbolize the cross's power to
Lift Us From Ashes from sin to Grace
from ashes to Resurrection which is Our
Hope for Christ now another tradition is
of course no meat today and then none on
Fridays as well during Lent we got mass
times for you on our website at
8newsnow.com for now live in The
Newsroom Lauren negretti news now